Scotland
just
isn't what you think one of the most fun
things about quantumania is we are
taking our characters into this entire
universe the quantum realm under the
guidance of Peyton Reed Batman's
becoming one of our most beloved
characters in Beloved franchises he
loves these characters and like us he
knows we can do something totally unique
Peyton Reed he has a really strong
Vision he's able to weave in and out of
action and the humor and the Heart
this is my third Ant-Man movie and
because that we were determined to make
the third one essential and a real
Trilogy camper the Epic nature of the
film you want to experience on the big
screen
[Music]
it's so transportive and visually
striking
this movie it's a
the sheer size and scope of it was
tailor-made for IMAX in 3D I feel like
you can't get a big enough screen for at
man of the WASP Quantum Mania